great so hello everyone welcome to um
our first session of the morning here in
the main room our first speaker is going
to be Oka fandal he is the leader of the
payment machine learning team at Uber um
which among other things works on
automatically detecting fraud in
payments for Uber services using machine
learning and he's going to talk to us
about his team moved from correlation
driven machine learning to caus causal
driven machine learning and how this
helped to improve key business metrics
so please give a big uh round of Welcome
to
a good morning everyone and thanks
thanks for the warm welcome um so yeah
my name is Oka I work on machine
learning at Uber and today my talk is
about personalization and specifically
how causal driven machine learning plays
a critical role into how we do
personalization at Uber so quick intro
introduction on the agenda for today
first I do want to talk a little about
Uber and amdam one of the things I've
noticed so far throughout the conference
is that not that many people actually
know we have a tech presence here in
Amsterdam so I do briefly want to touch
about that as well and then we are going
to talk about the topic of Cal M I'll
give a brief high level introduction and
then we're going to talk about the fun
part a case study of how we applied it
at Uber um but first about Uber and mam
um so we recently opened a beautiful
European campus here in amam close to
amam South at tripless Park and there's
roughly a thousand people working from
there which are split between our Mia
operations and the tech Hub so most
people know that am Mia operations
happen from amam not many people
actually know we have a beautiful Tech
Hub here as well there's roughly 300
people spread across engineering product
design and data science working on all
kinds of problems but most specifically
we work on Global Payments from mam um
so that's my the team uh that I work for
as well um a small plug we are hiring as
well so if you're interested uh check
out the link um so I lead the EML team
here in Amsterdam and some of the use
cases we work on have to do with
payments um the first one has to do with
incentives um that's also the case study
so I won't go too deep into that as well
but we for example also work on payments
fraud where we try to make sure that we
detect fraudulent users on the platform
and prevent charge Backs from happening
then we also work on things like
Financial products where in some of the
markets we for example offer loans to
the drivers that work for us and we
leverage machine learning to make sure
that we give the the loan to the right
user um so that's on a brief uh uh
overview what our team does um and the
key part of uh the technique that we
leverage for some of these problems is
is caal ML and it's pretty interesting
to for me so far already see the topic
ofl being brought up in multiple talks
so far which is super encouraging
because also for us we've seen the the
value it
has and if you think about what makes
Cal ml different from classic ml is that
classic ml focuses on what we call
Association if you follow the framework
from from JJ pill um where you have
specific features in the in the context
of supervis learning and you have a
response variable and you try to ensure
that the features correlate with a
specific response variable calll however
focuses on the intervention what happens
if we take a certain action and from a
business perspective that's ultimately
what we're interested in because we're
in the business of making sure that we
make the right business decisions so in
that sense also purely on a theoretical
basis calll makes a lot more sense than
classic ML and when you look at the data
you also see that they have different
data structures we all know how typical
classic ml data sets look like with
again typically an x uh which is your
features and then you have your Y which
is your target label which is what
you're trying to to predict most
supervised learnings uh problems look
like this a classic ml uh problem uh
looks very different from a c ml data
set in that sense where you also have
your your features uh and your y
response as well but then we introduce
what we call the W column so this has to
do with the intervention and the
interesting thing about caal m is that
we need to predict the counterfactual
value so what you see here with y0 and
y1 for every user or every unit in our
training set we can only observe the
outcome for one of the actions so if we
for example give one B business decision
to you and another business decision to
the other person we can only observe
once so the key question behind call M
is how can we estimate that
counterfactual value so that data set
that sense looks also a lot more uh
different a key part behind effective
Cal m is what we call randomized
experimentation often referred to as
running a B test and there's a few key
assumptions that need to be met in
general for Effective caal Mel but the
biggest benefit of running a experiments
is that you satisfy these assumptions
for free and one of the nice things
about working as Uber is that we run a
lot of experiments at any given point in
time there's over thousand experiments
running and all of these experiments
kind of give us training data for free
um so we run for example experiments
across writers trying different out
trying out different versions of the
home screen maybe we want to test out a
new experience for the drivers we run an
AB test for that as well well or maybe
even new versions of the ranking
algorithm where we train a new model
that we want to compare with the old
version so experimentation in that sense
for a caal male perspective gives us a
lot of free training data which is
great and ultimately why caal Mel such a
key part to our personalization strategy
has to do with the individual treatment
effect if we think about AB testing in
general what we're interested in is what
we call the average treatment effect you
have to make a decision based on what
works best on average for the entire
population um and that sense that's
where that average treatment effect
comes from but there is some suboptimal
decision making here because you have to
make a choice where some others might
have preferred the other choice so
that's where it or individual treatment
effect comes in because with KL you're
able to estimate for every user what is
the most efficient decision so rather
than giving a sort of a one- siiz fits
all decision to everyone we can focus on
the individual and in that sense becomes
a key part of how we approach
personalization so that's how it works
on on the high level um but now to the
fun part of of the case study at Uber um
first I want to see a show of hands who
here has ever received a promotion from
Uber either via email or
SMS a lot of hands who has received more
than
one for a consumer focused business like
ours promotions and incentives are a key
uh way for us to attract users to the
platform either by attracting new users
or to make sure that existing users
spend more on our platform and
optimizing how we spend that incentive
has been a key problem for us to solve
because there's a lot of money involved
so every percentage Improvement that
we're make here um brings more more
value to the
business and the goal for us is to make
sure that the right promotion goes to
the right user at the lowest cost so
assume here we have a problem where we
have 10 uh three different incentive
structures on the one hand we have 10
times 50% off on your next 10 trips or
maybe 10 times 20% off or maybe 10 times
10 10% off what we ultimately want to do
is to figure out for each user what is
the lowest cost you would be converting
to taking those next 10 trips so if you
are a user who would already take the 10
trips at 10% we want to give you the 10%
because if we then give you 50% we're
basically spending too much money on the
incentive for you to take an action that
you would have otherwise taken as as
well so that's ultimately what we try to
predict is what is the highest
incrementality that's what we typically
refer to to make sure that our campaigns
and our incentives are as efficiently
spent as possible so our typical
workflow on a high level looks like this
so usually we start with an experiment
where we randomly assign uh different
treatments to a broad set of users and
the goal here as I alluded to earlier is
that with experimentation you satisfy
the assumptions behind effective causal
m for free so running these experiments
allows us to create that training set
without really having to worry about
that problem problem of the
counterfactual then the second phase um
we combine the data that we've gathered
from those experiments with features
about individual writers so this for
example has to do with how did this user
interact with the previous Pro promo how
long have they been active on the
platform features that relate to how are
you acting on the platform so far so by
combin combining those features with the
experiment data that we gather from
those randomized experiments we create
our data
set and then we train our model and
basically uh use that to select Riders
so by being able to estimate the
individual treatment effect for each of
the writers we can figure out we should
give this specific promotion to you and
that promotion to another one and that
way we can make sure that the uh
campaign is spent uh most
efficiently then for some of the
campaigns that we run they are oneoff so
we run an experiment we execute the
campaign for the broader population and
that's done for other campaigns however
they may run continuously um and for
that especially if you think about from
a retraining perspective we need to make
sure that we continue to gather that
randomized data so that we can for
example in a couple of months retrain
that same model again with a clean
randomized uh data set um so there's
sort of a suboptimal execution of that
campaign here but that's a fair tradeoff
with long-term retraining of the models
um so that's how it works on a high
level um but now to the fun part of how
it works under the hood so if we come
back to our problem statement ultimately
we're trying to make sure that we make
the optimal decision of who should get
the promo um to maximize what we call
incremental GB so GB is what we refer to
internally as Revenue subject to a
specific promo budget constraint because
a lot of these campaigns have specific
uh campaign budgets Associated as well
so there's a few components to it here
as well if you look at the formula the
first one has to do with incremental GB
again Revenue um we have both the
revenue for the users who do get the
promo and the users who don't have the
promo but the goal for us is to estimate
what would have happened if you were in
the other group another part of this is
that treatment decision what is the
variable uh the the the W variable here
so for example one for treatment or zero
for
control and then you have the cost that
we are spending on the promotion so
sometimes these campaigns as you saw in
the example as well are pro are are
percentage based so um these are not
hard dollars but they are percentage
base of 10% off in the next 10 trips so
we also need to estimate how many trips
are you actually going to take what is
the value of those trips so for us to be
able to estimate what the cost is we
need to not only know how the promotion
looks like but we also need to know how
much money are you actually spending
because the cost for us on that
incentive is 10% of the revenue that
you're spending on our platform and that
again that cost is subject to a specific
budget so that is overall the the
problem statement so if you break it
down to our it estimation framework
there's essentially two key components
one is our spend estimator where again
we need to estimate how much money are
we spending on that specific promotion
for that specific user and we want to be
able to know that for different
incentive structures then we have what
we call the GB estimator where we
basically try to predict how much money
are you spending on the platform and how
much money um are you uh spending on the
different circumstances so we need to be
able to see if you are assigned a
different promotion how much money would
you then be spending on our
platform that together forms into this
efficiency metric which we call igb per
dollar spent so essentially what is the
ROI of a specific campaign and for a lot
of the campaigns that we run we also
have minimum uh Target values where we
need to make sure that uh our campaigns
are as run as efficiently as as possible
um and that igb per dollar spent is also
a combination of the spent estimator and
the GB estimator so you can already see
the formation of the interdependency
between the different tasks that we need
to estimate here so if you sum that up
in the overall task that we are working
on here is that we need to learn
estimators for three different things so
one is the estimator for spend how much
money are we spending on each individual
promotion the GBS for for for all of the
treatment groups involved so if you are
uh uh getting one treatment versus the
other we need to be able to estimate how
much money would you otherwise receive
and then of course we need to estimate
that igps our efficiency metric which is
both a function of GB as well as spent
so if you think about it there's a few
challenges with this the first one has
to do with um the just what we call the
fundamental problem of causal inference
and that is only one of the observations
we can observe so if you are assigned to
one specific treatment group we only
know what happens in that specific
treatment group and we don't know
necessarily what happens in the other
treatment group now the fact that we use
randomized experimentation to generate
our training set helps us solve that
fundamental problem the bigger
challenges however is how to do this in
in an efficient and scalable manner
because as you see on the estimators
here as well there's a lot of
interdependencies going on here where
how much we're spending on the promotion
depends on how much money you're
spending on our platform so there's all
these interdependencies happening here
where on the service they all look like
individual estimators but behind the
scenes they all depend on each other and
how to do this at an Uber scale makes
the challenge even more complex because
we have on average 100 million users
active on the platform so for us to be
able to figure out this user should have
this promotion and this users should
have have that promotion is an extreme
uh challenge for us
sometimes so if you break it down these
are essentially the four estimators that
we want to estimate so we have our spend
estimator our treatment GB estimator our
control GB estimator and then our igps
estimator so four um problems that in
the past we sort of treated like
independent problems so we for example
use traditional machine learning where
we would individually um estimate all of
these values but as you saw in the
previous slides as well there's a lot of
interdependencies happening here where
all of the functions all of the
estimators kind of are dependent on each
other again the amount of GB that you
spend on the platform is a function of
which promotion you get um the amount of
cost that we're spending on that
specific campaign is also a function of
how much money you're spending on the
platform and we saw that in the past if
we treated that as separate estimators
using more traditional machine learning
methods as part of the CML
uh ecosystem is that we were not
necessarily able to capture that into
dependency so it did work for quite a
while um pretty well in terms of how we
optimized our our incentive spend but we
did realize that we weren't able to
capture that in the dependency and
that's when we started thinking a little
bit more about how do we want to solve
the that specific
problem and that's when we came up with
uh neural networks so one of the
beautiful things about neural networks
is they are much better at capturing
that inter dependency between some of
these estimators especially thanks to
the unique properties such as back back
propagation it allows us to um optimize
multiple objectives at the same time and
capture that interdependency between all
of these estimators a lot
better and inspired by the work of uh uh
from from work on why learner we
introduced this architecture called
multitask y learner and as you can see
here beautifully in the visualization of
how the neural network looks like you
can on one hand see the interdependency
between all of the individual parts of
the neural network so you can for
example see that the promo features only
impact um the parts of the network that
have to do with the treatment group um
and that way we are able to separate the
features uh what we call the writer
features so that has to do with again
what I alluded to earlier with um how
did you respond to previous campaigns
and other behavioral uh character
characteristics that we can observe on
the platform
and that together um in the past we sort
of treated as one data set but by
specifying it as a neural network we're
much able much better able to uh to
separate that from each other and still
have one single neural network so you
can see here that we start with the wrer
features as part of the neural network
and then the promo features only impact
um the the the different treatment
related parts of the network so that way
we not only have one single Network that
fits all of the estimat where in the
past we would have four different single
models that would need to be run so also
purely from a scalability perspective it
gives us a lot more
efficiency so coming back to our initial
user base so usually when we start a
campaign there's an initial selection of
users that we want to Target it for
example has to do with um specific Geo
locations maybe we want to run a
campaign in in the US or a campaign in
the Netherlands for example and one of
the the things we've seen in in recent
years is that um our our business
basically consists of two verticals
right now we have on the one hand our
taxi business and on the other hand our
delivery business so in some markets
that can be food delivery and in other
markets that can be grocery delivery and
one of the ways we've seen work most
effectively for us is if we can upsell
one user to or one uh user using one
vertical to the other vertical and that
way especially with the increased spend
on advertising dollars today having an
internal tool for us to basically serve
as a marketing Tool uh allows us to be
much more efficient so the overall use
usefulness of this tool for us to figure
out we have a user that has been taking
trips to the airport for the last 5
years maybe they're now also interested
in food delivery let's give them some
extra discounts or some extra coupons
for them to spend on the flat platform
has become a bigger problem for us as
well um to do that more efficiently so
that's typically how these these
problems start out and if you apply that
it estimation framework this is how that
typically looks like so on the one hand
we have our bigbs so this is our
efficiency metric where we're interested
in um you know what is the incremental
GB that we're getting for every dollar
spent so for a lot of these campaigns as
I said earlier we have a minimum
efficiency Target where we're interested
in um uh where we sort of have a minimum
Benchmark that we want to meet for every
campaign otherwise we're not even
interested in in running it and then we
have uh the spend which is again a
function of how many trips you're taking
on a platform as well and then depending
on the budget we have for a specific
campaign um we we can make that decision
so for example here in the hypothetical
example on the screen you see that we
have for this specific campaign a budget
of seven um and our minimum Target value
for the efficiency so the ROI of a given
campaign here is uh is 2.5 so you can
see here that we need to select only the
thir the first three users because these
are the only users um that have that
that meet that minimum Benchmark of 2.5
and um that's the beautiful part of
using hypothetical examples they also
sum up to a budget of seven here um so
that is how these uh uh problems are
typically solved and by ranking the
users that way we can estimate what is
our overall uh effectiveness of of the
campaign and what we have seen is that
since we started moving from machine
learning based architectures to deep
learning based architectures the overall
efficiencies of the campaign that we run
grew substantially so capturing that
interdependency of all these estimators
separately allowed us to basically
increase our efficiency Target and again
because because uh upselling uh
promotions to users has become more and
more critical for our business that was
a key workstream for us and yeah that
way we were able to to make uh to to
create a lot of efficiencies here
um conference talk is of course nothing
without a little plug here um So based
on some of the learnings we've had from
developing Cal models at Uber for the
last couple of years uh a few years ago
we open source this package uh called
Cal ml available on uh open source for
for python um and based on the learnings
we've had on developing some of these
models at Uber um we open source this
package with a few Suite of uh uplift
modeling algorithms so this is both uh
focus on the the classical meta Learners
as well as some of the neural network
implementations as well so I would
highly recommend you to try it out if if
not already um and it's open source now
so we're always looking for contributors
as as
well um so that wraps up my talk for
today um with that thank you so much and
yeah open for any
questions